hello I am the new health and safety
executive officer for the Atlantis
Expedition and I have to tell you guys I
am incredibly excited I'm so excited
I've decided to do this video diary my
brother when he heard I was getting this
job he's the health and safety guy over
at the SGC at the moment here where I am
at the
moment he told me do not take this job
it's going to be a nightmare everything
will try and kill you it's going to be
you'll just be writing risk assessments
every five minutes but guys I tell you I
just think it's going to be really
really exciting I can't tell you look
there's going to be no gold there's
going to be no replicators we're not in
a base that gets invaded every five
minutes that's under a massive Mountain
so you've got nowhere to escape too it's
going to be great and at the end of the
day it's the Atlantis a City built by
the Ancients there are going to be
incredible wonders and magic and just oh
it's going to be an adventure and I
cannot wait to do these video diaries
even though I know no one's going to get
to see them to Chronicle though
everything we get to see I can't wait
it's going to be
amazing we've been here 24
hours we're
underwater we can't get home and we're
under
water I'm going to have to do a risk
assessment where everybody has to wear
water wings or rubber ring around their
waist
now apparently is well The Shield's
failing so in a minute we're all going
to be really
underwater but look it looks like we're
going to they're going to pop up to the
surface like a bloody rubber ball or
something
but it's not a good
start but at least look at least look
it's like one of those nights out you
know that starts a nightmare but ends up
being amazing I think it's going to be
bit like that okay it's not a great
start but hey we're here we're at the
Atlantis okay there are space
vampires spa space
vampires at least the go W just buried
themselves into the backyard and took
over your body these guys literally suck
the life force out of you through their
hands now don't get me wrong I don't
understand the science of sucking life
force out what are they doing sucking
your fluids or something I don't quite
get what's happening but space
vampires and the guy in charge this
Shepherd he's worse than sg1 put
together he's first mission first
mission first time off the base he wakes
up a billion space vampires who does
that how do you even do that
look my
nerves how many risk assessments am I
going to write to deal with space
vampires and because they they suck
through your chest
apparently big collar ain't that ain't
going to help we're going to have to
like wear metal plates or something on
our
chests my brother was right this is way
worse the space vampires they have the
queens and the Kings I suppose they're
all like big teeth and Sharpie and thing
and sucky but then they've got all these
like worker
wrestlers massive muscular face with no
faking faces they're like every 1980s
horror movie Slam together and they
don't want to kill you they want to
kidnap you can you think of anything
more terrifying freaking space
vampires
but still in the Atlantis it's still
going to be some amazing things to find
and I'm sure there'll be an adventure
and
look we defeated the goal I'm sure we
can defeat The
Wraith it'll be fine Jesus
was been here a couple of months
now we got out of the water we we
surfaced
and then a big wave came and we nearly
ended up underwater again but we got
through
that and we started exploring
this sorry thought I heard
something we started exploring the city
a bit
more at least at the
SGC no broom CED ever came to life and
tried to kill us all here it's a possib
ility it would seem that the Ancients
when they
left left all of their technology behind
all of their experiments all of their
weapons designed to defeat The
Wraith a fight they lost by the way we
think we're going to do okay but the
Ancients a million years ahead of us
couldn't fight them
but actually all of these experiments
seem to be 10,000 years later still on
and we keep finding
them I am terrified to touch
anything I went into a room last week
that I thought was a toilet and actually
it was some sort of secret death
ray just sat there on the
side I have to write the risk
assessments for all these things and the
risk assessment at the moment just reads
don't touch anything I'm going to have
have to insist that Rodney McKay gets
tied to a chair because he keeps
touching everything my brother used to
always tell me about Samantha Carter and
now she blew up a star once I'm pretty
sure rodne M Kay is going to do that
before
lunch I'm I'm terrified what he might
do my nerves are
shot it does
seem honestly it doesn't matter what the
people of Stargate command do they just
seem to find danger wherever they go
I've never thought they'd find Space
vampires and then a City full of death
Rays oh and nanites nanites are a
joy it does remind me though that at
least we're not going to get any
replicators there is no logical
sense or reason for why we would end up
getting replicated here I keep thinking
every time somebody mentions a nanite
ghost or something that next thing's
going to be replicators but no can't
happen can't
happen can
it as long as it's not the human
replicators with
the if we get out there though and we
find some human allies in our fight
against The Wraith maybe that'll make
things a little bit better just maybe
okay even the humans here hate us and I
can't blame them we woke up the bloody
wraith on our first visit literally
first planet we went to woke up the
entire wraith who have now gone on just
to start calling everybody they kill
everybody they come
across and it's completely our
fault all of the human populations
around here now hate
us and are trying to kill us as
well it's not their
fault we completely screwed everything
up and we're here safe because we're
under a massive Shield they have no
Shield wonder why they hate us so
much it just Jesus what was that Christ
every time there's a noise I jump
through my
skin n my
nerves the only thing that's keeping me
sane is knowing that we're not going to
get any
replicators I think I can cope as long
as we don't get any
replicators I people in mustaches live
with them this is very
itchy ah
St I reckon um I do look a little bit
like Tom C that kind of looks like Tom
cic oh [__] oh Jesus oh
God
ow I'm sorry if I've ruined the Illusion
for you it was
me it's just
me so I should put my glasses sh look
look it's
me I Hur